back atcha boy psychobabble airplane
picking your brain so it just I think
it's a nice luxury thing it's good boy
kanye right here very i better be here
okay let's say here Oh lobotomize animal
before me be warned and just as I feared
so you put down in any event that's
castrated nickname is his ol what let's
say here it wasn't then oh ok what
second enough J sass I got [ __ ] that I
can't buy just hanging out all day that
guy outside here hello sir you are an
unusual specimen between the extreme yet
you have no such will you indulge me
yes yes held like okay what weapon ah
you know I don't know what it is perhaps
what if you're ready haha look did he
doesn't know Thank You the bottom I oh
but once the heart hmm okay
and he says
sweet you get it I get this speech
[ __ ] up ok let's show
I don't understand how you can stand
those legs fates [ __ ] was when I just
[ __ ] put up a speech right yeah yeah
yeah that breaking news time oh stop the
presses okay oh oh okay
this guy i got i gotta introduce myself
to the sexy honey did you retrieve it
why if you he's good
we have yeah okay there's glowing red
scar from that
it
well yes that is me
ok
he's a doctor eight the [ __ ] is dr.
eight